これリストだけ言って進んだ方がいいかもしれませんね
ニッスョク・ニッスョはこれで日本語でどうなったでしょう
依縁と新依縁ですね だから言葉見たっても
で  なんか同じことを繰り返してるんではないかなと思うかもしれませんだけどね
まあニッサイ ウパニッサイ
これは意味はあの 大体こういう感じの意味なんですね
例えば 子供にすごい行儀がいい友達ができたと思うと
その子供はやっぱり友達の影響で自分も行儀のいい人になっちゃうんですね
よく真面目に頑張っている仲間に入ったら
自分もなんとなく真面目な人間になってしまう
で もうどんな場合でも大体そういう風になってしまうんですね
悪い人間の中に入ってしまえば
その人々の影響で自分もなんとなくまあ悪い人間になってしまっちゃうんですね
で 例えば自分の心がすごく明るいとする
それでもかなり雑音のあるところにいると
雑音のあるところにいると
どんどんどんどんどんどん心がもう悩み始めて
混乱してしまっちゃうんですね
あれずっと入るともう我慢できなくなっちゃうんですね
本来はその人は落ち着いている人かもしれませんだけど
だから周りの影響でそうなってしまう
で 部屋の中でいると何かすごくつまらなくなってくる
で なんで人が外へ出て公園なんかにいて散歩をしますかというと
この公園のおかげで心がまた明るくなってしまう
そういう風にこの影響のことを言ってるんです
だからこの条件というのは原因でもあって条件なんですね
で 例えば悪い仲間の中にいる人が悪くなる
だからAさんがなぜ悪くなったか
原因は何ですかというと
仲間が悪かったから悪くなったと
だから原因が仲間であって
結果がAさんが悪くなったと A
さんの悪さが結果なんですね
そこで この仲間がどのように影響
この原因を作ったかというと
影響を与えるということで働きかけたんです
悪い仲間と一緒にいた
そういう影響から悪くなったんですね
例えば 人があなた悪い人間になりなさいと説教したんだからといって悪くなるわけじゃないでしょう
だから原因はどのように結果になるために働きかけたかということなんですね
その場合は影響を通して働きかけるんですね
だからニッサイと言うんですね
ウパニッサイ ニッサイっていうのは
大体まあ付き合うような即パーリ
即語で パーリ語の即語の意味っていうのはね
誰かと一緒にいるとかね
まあ影響を受けるとか
そんな風な意味なんですね
これは物質的な世界ではこのわかりやすい例があるんです
例えば磁石と一緒に鉄の何か入れておくと
置くと鉄のものも磁石になっちゃうんですね
だから磁石 磁場がありますから
その中に磁石的な働きが何もない普通の鉄の何か釘とかなんとか入れておく
同じ磁場の中にいるでしょう
それで知らないうちにあの鉄の釘も磁石になってしまうんです
磁場の中の分子もやっぱり並んで並んでしまって
結局磁石なんですね それは影響なの
ウパニシャッドなんですね
何か強引に働きかけたって違う方向で働きかけたじゃないんです
磁場の中に入ればそれだけで十分です
それからこのトランスフォーマー
日本語で何と言いますか
電気で使うトランスフォーマーの変
変電何ですか 変 変圧器
変電器というか変圧器というか
ちょっと言葉わかりませんだけど
あので 一つのコイルがあって
そのコイルの中で電気が流れて流れて出て行っちゃうんですね
その隣にもう一つコイルがあるんですね
それとこちらは何の関係も繋がりがないんです
でも前のコイルの巻いてる数とこちらの巻いてる数に
この割り当てによって電圧が変わっちゃうんですね
繋げてるわけじゃないんです
高圧電線があるでしょうに
それは直接家の電気で繋げてるわけじゃないんです
ある機械があって その機械にまず電気を与えて 100 ボルトにしてくれるんですけど
実際には繋げてないんです
中で 今の場合は電気 電線が繋げてないとリード線が光らないでしょうに
でも高圧電線と家庭の家の 100 ボルトの電線は繋げてない
全くもコンタクトない
でも一緒にいるんですね
あの電圧 変 変圧器の中では一緒にいるんですね
そこで電圧が違う電流が新しく生まれてくるんです
あの電気を作る あのモーターじゃない
その場合はダイナモというんですけどね
[笑い]回すでしょ タービン
タービンというやつをね
で 水と全然関係ないでしょうしね
水があれ回ってくるだけで
その中にいっぱいコイルというかね
入っていて で 周りで磁場があったりして
関係ないんだけど つながりがないんだけど
そこで電気というものが生まれちゃうんですね
その影響の中で その関係なんですね
ウパニッセイっていうのは
例えば私が手でガラスを殴ったならば
ガラスが割れちゃいますけど
直接つながりがあるんですね
手がガラスにちゃんとぶつからないと割れないんです
あの場合は直接影響がなくても
原因が影響を与えるということで結果が出すんですね
だから原因自体がいろんな形で結果が出すということで
今の場合というのは影響を与えるということで
ニッセイ・ウパニッセイ全く同じ意味なんです
で あの これ今日はちょっと難しいですから
ちょっと休憩取っても構いませんだけど
ん？４時半で終わりますか
ん？僕は専務教でこれ終わろうと思ったんだけど
まああの 休みながら喋りますけど
えーと この影響も前の今書いたものじゃないんです
あのウパニッセイ ニッセイ・ウパニッセイという 2つについてね
で それは私たちにはよくあることで
あの人間関係の中でもね
ある人々のところに行ったら
やっぱり自分の心は変わるということはよくあるんですね
だからこの これ変わるだけのことで
いい方向に変わるか悪い方向変わるか
それはもう別に関係ないんだからね
である人と話すと自分の気持ちも悪くなるとかね
ある人と一緒にいると自分の気持ちも良くなるとかね
そういう風にこの人間関係でよくあるんですね
で そこでこれは確実にこのニッセイ・ウパニッセイパッチェなんですね
だからこの電 変電器と同じく
もう何もつなげてるわけじゃないんです
この相手の心のエネルギーが自分の心の中に強引に入ってしまって
自分の心は自分の意思に反して変化させたんだとということじゃないんです
そこは理解した方がいいと思いますね
で そういうあの間違ってる考え方は世の中にあるんですね
あの人はすごい悪い波動を出しているんだから
私も時々そういう言葉を使いますけどね
その悪い波動を出しているんだから
それは自分の心の中に入ってしまって
自分の心が悪くなったと
あの人はいい波動を出しているんだから
それは自分の心に入って自分の心も良くなったとかね
そういうのは実体論であってね
だからそこでまたいろんな迷信やらね
生まれてくるんですね
それはただその影響の中にいるだけ
磁石のそばに鉄の釘を置いただけであって
磁石は別に何もやってないんです
だから もし磁石が何かやるならば
磁石の力が消えるはずなんですね
磁石のそばに もう例えば釘一本置いておく
それは磁石になったらもう一本置いておく
それ磁石になったらもう一本置いておくと
それで 1万本置いておいたって
あの磁石はそのまんまなんです
だから磁石のエネルギーは消えたわけじゃないんです
もし磁石にはこのある一定の一定のエネルギーがあったならば
それは釘に奪われたならば
やがて磁石の磁石は消えるはずなんですね
そうはないでしょうに
ある？それは違う原因です
それは科学的なことだから
あるかないと私はあまりわかりませんだけど
まあ一応別に いろいろそれそれとか流れていくんだからね
流れていったならば消えますけどね
で まあ流れていくならば消えますし
それは磁石にする方法によりますし
で まあ消えるんですけど
それを消える原因はまた違うんです
例えば一緒に置いておくと
あの磁石の磁場がきれいに流れなくなっちゃうんですね
だから自分の磁場が邪魔に
邪魔されるんですね その邪魔される反応で自分の磁石力も弱くなる
でもお互いに何も与えたわけじゃない
それでも ただ 自分のエネルギーは流れない
流れないんだから まあちょっと弱くなったっていうことだけなんですね
それはまた全く別な原因で
今言ってるのはこのウパニシャッドという条件で考えちゃうと
相手は別に何かこちらに強引に入れるわけじゃないんです
だから気持ち悪い人と一緒にいると自分も気持ち悪くなる
それで気持ち悪い人の気持ち悪さが薄くなるかというと
そうはなりませんね もしこちらから何か物を移動するんだったら
もう減ってしまうんですね
ですからこのだから逆に考えちゃうと
あの 例えばたとえ悪いの悪い仲間に至っても
自分の心が悪くならないようにすることは可能なんですね
あの人はよく怒るんだから怒ってしまいますというのは
あんまり言い訳にならないんです
弱い人の場合は もうそんなもんなんですぐ影響を受ける
で 自分にとっては影響を受けない
別にあの人何か怒りなさい
怒りなさいと言ってるわけじゃないし
怒りのエネルギー 自分の心の中に注いでいるわけでもないんですから
自分をプロテクトすることもできるんですね
だから 人間関係に出てくるこの影響の場合は
そこを自己コントロールできるんです
悪い影響を受けないようにと
いい影響だったら受けるようにと
という自己コントロールができるんです
もしこの実体的に魂みたいな実体的に考えちゃうと
これ不可能なんですね
悪い心が悪い 暗い人と一緒にいると
確実にも暗くならなくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますから
その場合はなぜならばその人は悪いエネルギー出してるんだから
悪いのが出してる人は悪いのが出したらどこかで悪いのが消えるはずでしょうし
そういうことじゃないんだから
ですから この あの ただその影響の中でいる
そういうことだけで自分がそう悪くなってしまう
そうならないようにすることもできます
じゃああの それだったら次の
条件に行きます 次の条件はプレ
プレジャート パッチェと言うんですね
それはまあ この場合はこの言葉でいいんです
先生縁と 前に生まれてやること
あの因果法則でそれをどのようにするかと
後で少々だけ説明します
それ十二四十二四終わって終わってから
今はちょっと理解だけでいいんです
例えばこちらで 今我々は何かアビダルマクラスやってますね
それやるためには こちらのこの建物
部屋が先にあることは必要なんです
それ先になければクラス暮らしにならないんです
クラスやりましょうと思ったら
そちらにまずもう部屋があるということは
まずあってからなんです
部屋も何も机もないんならば
先に部屋を作って机を持ってきて
椅子を持ってきて それからクラスをやるということなんですね
ですから ある出来事には
ある出来事を起こるためには
他の現象が先に 起きている必要があるんですね
分かりやすい 何か見ようと思うと
やっぱり先に目がないと見えないでしょうに
見たいんだから それから目を作ろうということは成り立たないんですね
目が先にあるだからものを見る
やっぱりそういうのは先に生まれておかないと
そういう風にこのやっぱり先にあって
それが次の現象を作る
披露宴やりましょうと
あげましょうと思ったら
やっぱり先にそれなりのホテルがありますかどうかね
調べて そこあるんだから
じゃあそこで披露宴という風になっちゃうんですね
日常生活の中で 私たちは何か何か希望している結果があって
例えば結婚式の場合は披露宴やることは結果であって
自分はそういうことをやりたいと
その結果を起こすために
その結果を出すために
前もっていろんな準備をしておかなくちゃいけないんですね
だから先に体があるんだから
次から次へと心が生まれるっていうことは
そういうことなんです
我々に目があるんだから見えて
そのように知識がまた働いていく
耳があるんだからもう聴覚が生まれて
それから知識が働いていく
それプレジャートと 先に生まれていて
次に あの その先に生まれていなくちゃいけないんです
ただ 暮らしの場合は やっぱり先に机があって
椅子があって 小屋があって
今もあるんですね だから暮らすという現象が成り立つんです
でも この部屋やら机やら椅子やら
それはもう先にも用意しておいておかないと暮らすという現象が生まれません
それはプレジャート 次に難しいのは次の言葉なんですね
パッチャージャト パッチャージャトっていうのは日本語で何ですか？後生縁ですね
それはちょっと私にはちょっと説明できません
まあ意味は後から生まれてきて
前にいた人に影響を与えるということなんですね
だから本当は原因は後から生まれるんという
おかしいんですけどね
でもそういう働きがあります
夫婦が新しく男と女が結婚していて
それで後から入り込んじゃうでしょうね
子供が 入ったら全部生き方やらすべてもう全く変わってしまっちゃうんですね
子供が生まれたら 自分の生き方
食べ方 もう何から何まで全て変わる
だから自分の生き方は完璧に変えた
それは原因は生まれてきた子供なんですね
でも子供は後から生まれるんですね
後から生まれたものは先にいたものに影響を与えて変化させる
という働き 因果法則の場合は
やっぱりそれはちょっとおかしいんですけどね
そう考えると 原因は後から生まれるんだと
で 原因が後から生まれて
先に結果があって 後から原因が生まれるということと同じことを言ってるんだ
それはありえないんです
だから これ条件なんですけど
結局は原因があって 次に結果が生まれるということは変わりません
ですから 家族の場合は夫婦が先にいて
それからの夫婦の生き方変える場合は子供が生まれてそれから変えるでしょう
だから子供が生まれてから変えちゃうでしょうに
だからやっぱり原因結果が後なんです
どう見たって だからそんな条件なくてもいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
まあ大雑把に考えればよく理解しやすいんですね
赤ちゃんが生まれたら
まあお父さんもお母さんもやっぱり生き方は全部変えちゃうでしょ
全部子供中心に変えてしまう
でもそれは先に夫婦がいた
それから原因が生まれて変えたということに
大雑把に見ればその通りなんです
やっぱり子供が生まれると同時に夫婦の生き方が変わりますから
やっぱり子供が生まれること先になっちゃうんです
よく考えると 赤ちゃんが生まれたということが先で
生活生活は変わりましたっていうことは後なんですね
それはもう見る角度によって問題が変わりますからね
違う角度で見ると やっぱり両親が先にいて
それから子供が生まれて
両親の生き方が変わると
見方だけなんでしょうね
思えば よく思えば だから要らないかもしれませんね
その条件  料理の場合でもいろいろありますからね
先にこれやって すぐにこれやるんだと
だから後から入る入れるものによって
まあ次に変化するということをね
で いろいろありますけどね
でもだからといって後から生まれてきたものが前のものに変化したという
だから原因が結果が先で
原因が後ということにはなりません
それがなんで因果法則でそんな変なところ
変な条件言ってますか？というで
やっぱりこの今の体が次の心に影響を与えるでしょう
だから体が先にあるんですね
まあただそれぐらいのことなんです
まあはっきり言えばなくてもいい条件なんです
それからちょっと意味が違いますからね
アセーワ で 次のはアセーワ・ナ・パッチェですね
これは就業 就業縁と書いてますね
ここで何を条件にしているかというと
この何か訓練していることが結果与えるんだと
いわゆる結果に影響を与えるんだと
でまあ 例えば皆様方はね
夏目漱石の小説を読んで大変感動する
そこで じゃあ 今日日本に来た人を捕まって
まあ私も全部読めませんだからね
私にしたっても だから私の例よりは私はすごくずるいんだから読めなくたっても読むいろんなずるい方法を知ってるんです
漢文でももう読むんです
本当は読めないんですけど
ちゃんと意味を取るんで
それずるいやり方なんです
だから勉強になったら僕はいつでも貸すんです
なぜならば他の人勉強するんだからね
それ時間取っちゃうんです
私は勉強しません その代わりになんとかして内容を理解する
漢字とか厳密に勉強して
漢字の組み合わせやら文法的なからくりとか
それをやるともう十年ぐらいかかっちゃうんです
すぐ即座にどうやって意味を意味を取れるかと
そのそういう方法を見つかったところで
もう読むと だからこの古い日本語にしたっても
全部わかりませんだけど
いろいろこといろんなことを
一つはこの背後関係と見る
もう一つは 人間の論理性っていうのはどうしても決まってるんだから
例えば小説なんか読む場合でもね
ああ おそらく次にこういうことを言わなくちゃいけないんだからね
この漢字 この言葉わからなくても
この人はこういうことを言ってるだろうと
で 次の言葉はわかりますから
ああ だからこういう言葉が出ている
よし 分かった そういうことにします
で どうしてもつなげない場合だけ辞書を引いたりする
英語の読み方もそういう読み方なんですね
全ての英語の単語を知る必要はないんです
途中で一つ言葉知らない言葉が出てきても
平気で読んでしまえば
あの言葉は後から分かってしまっちゃうんです
それは置いといて なんでそういう例を言ったかというと
まあ日本人であるならば
夏目漱石の小説を読んですごく深い感動をするんです
そこで今日日本に来た外人さんがあって
これはすごい面白い本ですよと
ものすごく深く人間の心の働きを書いている
もう立派な小説だよと
読んでみなさい あなたも感動するんだと
その人は感動しますかね
その人は外国人だっただからこちらから開けてみるんですね
あれおかしいなとかね
本はこちらから開けるもんでということさえも知らないんです
日本語の本だったら 我々から言えば後ろから開けるもんなんですね
後ろから読むもんなんですね
やっぱり日本語の本は後ろから読むもんだよぐらいも知りませんだからまるっきり感動しないんです
なんだこれと そこでなんである人がそこを見てすごく感動する
ある人は全くもう感動しないかというと
それは訓練の結果なんですね
こちらは長い間日本語を読むと日本語を理解するという訓練を持ってるんです
だから ただの白い紙に黒いインク塗ってるだけのことなんですけど
黒い紙にあのプリンティングインクですか
インク塗ってるだけ 何もないんです
その本の中に一言葉もないんです
で でも訓練ある人にとってはありとあらゆる感情の流れが生まれてきて
感動するでしょ だから原因は確かに本なんですけど
その感動生まれたという結果が作ったのは自分持っていた前の訓練なんですね
ですから 初めて日本に来た外人から見れば
ただ白い紙に黒いインキ無茶苦茶塗ってるだけのことなんです
何の意味も持たない そういうことで我々の訓練というか習慣というかね
によって結果が変わるんです
それもあの まあそれは条件といえば条件なんですね
それはやっぱりはっきりした条件なんですね
本を読んで感動するしますよと言ったっても
それでは決めません また
ちょっと条件が必要です
読めるかないかという
読めるならば感動しますよ
ですから条件で働くんですね
習慣という条件が働くんです
じゃあまあそこら辺で終了しましょう
で その条件がなぜ必要かというと
常にすべてのものは無常なんです
無常でないものは何一つもないんです
無常に目が覚めたら悟るんです
全ての煩悩消えるんです
でも人は一人も悟れませんね
解脱しません なぜですかというと
ずっと無常でないと認識した訓練があるんだからなんです
だから新しく無常ですよと
本当は無常ですよというふうな見方が変えてみるんです
それで悟るんですから
修行ということは必要な条件になっちゃうんですね
そういう意味があって
その条件使っているんです
じゃあどうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました